ORIGINALLY SCHEDULED FOR THIS
SUNDAY JANUARY 2,
THE CENTERS
SHARING THE DEFENSIVE F THE LEF
NOT FINDIT.
MERCER, A GREAT LOOK.
FROM THE ANGLE, THEY SCORE 10 A.
LOOK AT THAT TIC TAC TOE.
NO CHANCE FOR HIM COMITHE
AGAINST THE
DEVILS LAST SEASON PLAY
IN THIS
1st PLAY.
>> CRAIG: THE DEVILS DO NOT S,
CARLSON, TRAILING THE PLAY.
CARLSON FIRES, SCORES!
GO.
CARLSON SHOOTS IT AS QUICK ON 7
OCTOBER.
NET.
13 SETTING UP HISCHIER.
THE PUCK DEFLECTED DOWN TO PUCK
OVER.
HERE IS THE GIVE AND THE GO.
CAN NOT  MOVE, NOT GOING TO  OV.
HERETAKING TO SAFETY GET QUICKES
MOVING THE
PUCK.
GREAOUT.
BOQVIST, SMITH, WALKS THE LINE,
SKIPS IT
HE CAN NOT PUT6:44 TO GO.
HATHAWAY TO THE FRONT
DEFENSE
MAN, GRAVES, BACKHAND,
FOREHAND, HITS IT OUT OF
MIDAIR.
THAT IS A DOWD A FEW MISS HANDL
IT IS S IT.
HIS BACKHAND TO THE  PASS,
CUT DOWN BY ORLOV, RECOVERS,